it's funny though because sometimes
people hit me up you're like yo preach
is useless this and that and I always
laugh in my head because I'm like you're
probably out of like
you're like top three people that I
think I've learned the most from yeah
yeah and in light of that I got you a
little something okay okay you thought I
forgot about your birthday I didn't
forget about your birthday
like I said I'm not supposed to be here
you're still not my friend though
okay
today's topic goddamn you what what's
that I don't know there's a pep in your
talk what you mean as a pet I don't know
I don't know what's about this something
we about to talk about but there's a
Peck in your talk is that a good or bad
thing that's a good thing this is a good
thing of course because when you go all
right
today's topic is going to be some
[__] shooting another
[__] for no reason and then I'm
like ah [__] this shit's gonna be hella
emotional I'm not gonna lie guys you
read me like a book congratulations
congratulations
when you do this [__] and you're like
you just look at the camera you fix your
beard and you're like you don't know
what to say this shit's gonna be deep
and I'm like oh man today's a good day
what do we talk about I know today's a
good day but I was like you good hey my
[__] you get into your 40s
congratulations I know I've been in my
40s hey I'm just saying you just
recently celebrated right because once
it happened for you congratulations not
the subject he's talking no it is
congratulations you get into your old
keys or ages it's beautiful
yeah but now it's official it's
government stint yeah it different yeah
before you could claim it but now you
got the ID you just put it up in
people's faces like all right
[__] [__] go to my
house with their kids and they kids
calling me mister I'm like yeah you damn
right [__] yeah and he Don't Preach you
know at this point in life he's enjoying
some of the Finer Things ain't that
right preach I've always been yeah but
now you can afford it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and a lot of that I got
you a little something okay
okay you thought I forgot about your
book I think you forget about your
birthday
I got a little pit my step
I
open this box
this is some laughing you would like
cigars
looks like a cigar box
I even got a little humidifier so you
put that there you know since you were
top G now you gotta get lung cancer okay
don't don't call me that I'm not kid or
say Romeo Julieta Bueno okay yeah
I appreciate you yeah you know how I
feel about my pool business
okay
okay we got this all the way from
Ireland
is he here young one
Papa preach about the preacher all right
so in the old age you don't know nothing
about that don't you anymore yes yes I
appreciate it hold up hold up hold up we
got one more oh man what the [__]
thing right if you gonna have something
delicious such as a Cuban cigar
you gotta have the right drink to go
with it and that's why we come in right
here with this okay okay I took my times
to look up this stuff because I don't
know these Brands okay what is wrong
with you okay okay okay okay
you know what this is yeah I know I know
you don't but I know you do that's what
matters because it's a gift for you okay
what's wrong with you what's all this
congratulations that's wonderful
appreciation all right why are you
suspicious yeah yeah cause you
suspicious
it's a nice bottle right it's a good one
too
some good cognac thanks I've heard you
say cognac a few times
I heard you say cognac a few times
well I I heard you said uh [__] that
had a list I mean I didn't I mean
celebrate today hey hey I'm not saying
I'm down with X workers but
okay okay well thank you very much my
guy no worries yo yo pull up to the
cigars I never smoked a cigar you never
smoked this again never yeah let's just
do it bro
today's a big day what the [__] is wrong
with you today's a big day
he's weird right tell me I'm not being
weird bro it's a big game for you man
you're [__] weird bro but you don't
have a cutter this one I think it's just
you don't have a cutter well I don't
know what that is you're gonna have to
educate your boy well basically you have
to cut this edge off how do you cut it
with a cutter you can't just use a knife
I wouldn't suggest it even if it's a
good knife she will have good knives
yeah I do I bought some good knives off
Amazon
okay
it's weird
this is hella weird
I don't know what the [__] they've
gotten into this [__] you don't even
like smoke if you want to do that here
you don't even like the drink
that's not true I saw something about
him drinking Soju maybe it's Korean soju
that got him like that I don't know what
it is they don't even smoke like that
I'll smoke the whole thing okay
Hey listen I like me some spirits
okay you're going for okay go go a
little bit less for me yeah because I
got to see my mama oh you put a little
bit more than that put a little bit more
than that let me see my mama but he's
chew some gum
my mom smells alcohol from my breast
she's like okay supposed to see my mom
right after this
you can always tell her I'm just
comfortable I paid hey true true
my birthday barbecue the other day I
would I made a fire in my backyard and
she was talking about don't put more
wood in the fire I'm like hey hey who
pays the bill here
okay all right all right so show me how
this [__] works all right so basically
first and foremost you need to you need
to pre-burn this so it burns equally so
you just have to go like that to
pre-burn it okay okay just to evenly
burn interest okay so now you have a
nice burn you can even rotate it if you
want
it's an intake
and then you light it up
you're just inhale in and then exhaling
okay okay all right let's give this [__]
a shot you do it now you can do the
lighter part I'll do this part because
if I try to do both I'm about to [__]
this up I'm already intimidated by the
inhale exhale all right first and
foremost we have to remove the ring got
you got you I thought you just needed to
look at this just like whenever you're
gonna [__] somebody else's wife remove a
ring part
laughs
that was good that [__] caught me that
was good hey and you then you preach you
already know okay let's go let's do this
all right shout out to my Cubans shout
out to Destiny Destiny Cuban yeah damn
this is the whitest Cuban I know there's
a lot of white Cubans I know but he's
the whitest with blue Air and [__] this
[__] don't even dance
shout out to her
like
go ahead all right so then I go like
this
oh
not always Master Guard my leader
wait wait wait Cheers Cheers To Life
wow this is smooth because it's Rich
it was really easy that's how you
understand yeah I got all these bottles
in my house yeah this [__] it should hit
different you understand what I've had
the cigars and [__] like that and why is
this like [__] and I just like listen
to I just look into nothingness and just
have it yeah
there's a character in Kill Bill that
used to smoke a cigar like that that was
funny it was the pimp and he has all
these ugly ass [__]
did you check it you're fine you're done
with your glass I'm good so what else
what do you mean man I'm ready for some
[__] now
I almost pulled out my phone like I know
some [__]
just pass the corvall see yay
how's this entering the new chapter you
say you feel like the same I don't feel
no different
not really my knees hurt more
do you think you think because you feel
like you got most of the things you
wanted in life in place uh not really
I'm then I'm not done doing [__] I'm not
saying done but you got the foundation
for a lot of it you know what I'm saying
like yeah it's security that you feel
yeah definitely when it's not even
moving in the direction you're thinking
I definitely I definitely feel more
secure about this [__] about the [__]
that I'm doing I feel more secure
they're more grounded
but I still got a whole lot more to
achieve so
yeah yeah like I said I'm not supposed
to be here
like all my teachers were saying that
some of my biggest bullies were my
teachers they're talking about I'm not
gonna do nothing that's why I related so
much with
Michael B Jordan when he was called
corny and was able to put that [__] in
her face later on yeah yeah I was the
corner kid what's up now you know
come a long way but I'm the same
[__]
you're trying to keep your composer but
it's fairly miserably that's okay I am
what I am yes I'm still enjoying the
[__] out of this are you this is like a
I'll do this once I don't think I'll do
this again but under the right
circumstances I can be confused you get
me I know myself
that's by my house we'll do that outside
yeah we got to be the right occasion
can't be indulging these things too
often the Finer Things in life got to be
for the right time you do them too much
they lose their meaning then you start
to hate them I'm mad at you nobody
expected it and you know there's a bunch
of [__] that told you in your
face or in message that you would not do
nothing in your life there's
[__] that told you and I know
for a fact and I could name names but
I'm not gonna I know exactly the year
2017. [__] told you that you
would not be nothing in your life they
did nah you're not gonna succeed you're
not gonna do nothing
and we out here as puncturing events
that they're going to
give it back to the community back here
give me back to them [__] who have
some [__] to say even to the
[__] that had [__] to say it's
all good I'll be honest with you none of
that [__] ever even faced me even in the
slightest I think this is like part of
human beings that's a bit delusional
it's like which is a good thing in a way
it was like I think in my head I always
start working out maybe not to this
degree
but I always thought like nah I got
something
I don't care if anybody else sees it
you'd like people to be supportive never
really bothered me that people weren't
but yeah I think moments like this are
good you know sometimes you wait till
people are dead to give them their
flowers so I'm like not this year
no I'm not doing that no more I lost too
many people
absolutely
too quickly
that's actually probably been the
coolest part about this YouTube Journey
aside from like the success and [__]
like that what because I really feel
like over the course of the couple years
that we've done this together
I think I've become a better man
better family man
sure I've seen a better partner
you know the fact that I move my mom
closer and get my people around me I
think that's a prime function maybe
getting older but also the influences
around me and so
you know your birthday coming around
like you know what I'm grateful for
money
I am like wow Beyond this work
so that's well it's been cool because
you know
one of the big benefits of growing older
something that everybody seems to hate
for some reason is you get to watch the
people around you developing
if you're unfortunate sometimes it's not
for the better but if you are fortunate
you get to see people grow into
themselves grow into some of the things
that they want
and
that's worth celebrating every now yeah
that's why I celebrate life that's what
I got a whole bag tattoo about death
also well it's a saying in uh in Latin
and it's part of uh stoicism where
basically what it means is remember that
you're gonna die
so
it's just a way to be like yo when
things are affecting you or things are
going bad or whatever what not
try to be like hey remember you're gonna
die
so instead of focusing on this negative
[__]
focus on the negative prepare for the
negative prepare for the bad focus on
the positive but you have to prepare for
the bad
um
so sometimes people think I'm really
super negative about this [__] but I
want to make sure that I'm prepared for
the bad
because Murphy's Law
right
so
I prepare for the bad I remembered I'm
gonna die and that's what you know I'm
able to ride my bike and when I rev it
or I just push it too hard I'm like hey
you're doing too much right now it's
good that you got that self-control some
people are constantly looking for that
high don't do anything oh I get my high
somewhere else
like a cigar like a cigar like you know
sometimes I like to go to
uh I like to go to you know roller
coaster rider like that having a
motorcycle I like that it's doing
different things you know traveling
discovering places I love traveling it's
coming places that's great and
discovering places with people that you
love is even greater and giving back is
always good too so that's what I do
I give back different communities that
I'm part of
yeah
it's funny though because sometimes
people hit me up they're like yo preach
is useless this and that and I always
laugh in my head because I'm like you're
probably out of like
you're like top three
people that I think I've learned the
most from
oh same I could say the same thing and I
could say the same thing I think for me
oh
I think just being able to observe you
over the years
watching the decisions that you make
even professionally you know like I
think it's amazing what you've done
in regards to like the acting the
commercials the voiceovers the different
projects you take you're very out there
in that regards and some I think admire
a lot but I think even on the personal
side I think the way that you conduct
your life your relationship your family
life for me was very eye-opening
because it made me see a different part
of life up close on a semi-regular basis
so it gave me other things to strive for
or to look forward to or to build in my
life
with real examples that are close to me
you know because if you're not exposed
to it you don't know it right if you
ain't never seen it then how do you even
know where you want to go
well it's not that how you ever know
where you want to go it's really just
you don't know that there's other
options you're the opposite where you're
not out there
you reserve yourself
and when it's time to pop out is it has
even more worth you understand that's
another vision
the biggest power that I have right now
is being able to say no
I said yes to the cigar
foreign
means a lot
you're still not my friend though
[__]
you know what's so funny
I was like you and I know the dynamic
has changed but what we were seeing it
for a long time it was true
but it changed naturally over time the
more that we actually started spending
time together away from the work
and I just kept the meme going because
it pissed them off and I thought it was
funny too same same it's it's funny but
it's like you call me at whatever y'all
I need you here I'd show up not cause
you my co-worker because you my [__] I
think I think we've established the
professional boundaries so well
that now we can afford to move on to
something but I think I think it's a
different thing still I still like it's
really weird what I'm about to say but
you my [__] but you're not my friend
you're gonna have to explain this one
what I mean by that is
we've been through so much
so you said that I went hey [__] we
went through
haitially
listen even those you got me started
with this [__] I might re-upping those
you don't know you know me you know me I
drink right you gonna stop cause you
gotta get home after this you're gonna
say that for a different thing
okay
you can't tell me what to do but I
appreciate the fact that you know I'll
take your keys [__] no I'm fine
I'm not gonna die okay
you're gonna have to fight me
I'm not gonna do that bro we're not
doing that we're not doing that yeah
I'll snitch on you bro I call your wife
I'll call your mom call my wife yeah you
know you know that one my wife want to
be here and take my that's my [__]
keys yeah no I'm not doing that and
fighting over someone that's taking
that's so dumb I mean some people do
that I know but thankful I don't got any
friends with that that's not me that's
not I'm not that guy I'm not though oh
yeah oh yeah wait
I'm light-headed
[Laughter]
I thought Apple was a nickname
a lot of people did
that was the name I inherited from my
grandfather Abba you know what his name
is
I'm serious I respect that that your
gravel is not my foggy my grandfather
27 children you're what he had nine
wives and the [__] was blind
my grandfather was a top G was the
original red pill Guru
[Music]
wow that man was never an insult he was
getting [__] without no eyes and he was
he wasn't a Nico up yeah
he was the second coming of Emmanuel
Rastafari
gangster bro that's gangster [__]
that's against this [__] I used to walk
in this place he's like who is it
whose kid are you
yeah
that's a g that's what I remember my
grandfather gee
give me my chat which is what they chew
yeah yeah when you go to when you go to
Ethiopia we're doing that when we go to
Ethiopia we're doing chat
we're doing tests
apparently test can make you crazy
moonshine's wild I wanna I wanna get tez
crazy
set it up [__] talk about all
that money I talk about Ted's crazy
we can definitely set that [__] up um
but yeah
thank you
now let's get this money all right
that's it for today's video let us know
what you guys think we don't really give
a [__] today we celebrating [__] it's
a celebration [__]